Hi everyone, it's Jerry. I have an excellent game to share with you from round two of the
2023 Qatar Masters. On the white end, Alisher Suleymanov playing against Magnus Carlsen.
So let me first begin with the elephant in the room. Carlsen's opponent wore an analog
watch during this game, and that rattled him. It sparked a big discussion. Here are some
of the tweets that help to tell the story. I think what MVL had to say is on point. If
you'd like to go ahead and pause the video, read up on this all you want. My main focus
in this video is going to simply be on the chess. Okay, this game begins with d4. And
the opening, we work with b6, Queen's Indian defense. a3, Petrosian variation, no bishop
b4 check. Carlsen puts some pressure on c4. Defended, and Black says mission accomplished.
I got what I wanted. This little finesse with the bishop has pulled the queen away from
supporting a d5 advance. That's not to say d5 still can't be played. It could still be
played as a gambit. Alright, knight c3, c5, e4. You see the threat? It's a positional
one. Given time, white would like to next play d5, form a little triangle, and have
the bishop bite on a rock. Black is well aware of this, timely, breaks up the pawn trio.
Only after the structure has been addressed does Black continue to develop. Knight f3.
Okay, the follow-up is knight c6. A question I had for myself is, what happens if Black
goes after f2? Or in other words, what's happening after knight g4? How to defend? You might
think, well I could drop my knight back here. You don't have to run in reverse though. A
good move for white in this position is bishop g5, hitting the queen. And after f6, the bishop
is there in time. There is a more sophisticated variation, and that is to capture on f2 right
now. This is not a good path for Black. How would this one play out? We would end up with
a queen exchange, and white is down the exchange. However, this guy is cornered, and in time
white is going to win the knight. Soon we're going to have a two minor pieces versus rook
imbalance. Very good for white. So, in this game it is simply more development, space
for white on the queen side with tempo, the reply, bishop e7. What's very important to
note is that if Black instead drops the knight into d4, don't take the knight. If white takes
the knight on d4, the bishop would be invited to an excellent diagonal. There's all of a
sudden a pin, there's a problem on e4. f3 has its own issues, knight h5, queen h4 with
check. Okay, how should white play if knight d4? Move the queen right away. Not with the
intention to meet knight takes knight with queen takes knight, because the bishop would
be able to get to d4. The idea is to take on the doubled f pawns, and look at this g7
square. There's some coordinated pressure here, and queen side castles is right around
the corner. A very lively position ahead, to be sure. Okay, in this game, bishop e7,
bishop b2, Black's queen has an eye on the e5 push. She's working from afar, going to
c7 is asking for trouble. Alright, rook d1, Black castles, and the follow-up is bishop
to e2. e5 is close to maybe working as a pawn sacrifice, but do know if you play e5 right
now, after these captures, the queen gets to take with check. I bring this variation
up because once bishop to e2 is in there, this becomes a thing. If the queen isn't able
to get here with check, there's a trick for white. Now in the game it is d6, if instead
h6 is played, this is where we could see e5 working. If the knight moves, the pawn falls,
and if you take here, this is where there's no longer a check, and white has time for
this winning shot, knight d5. Queen is hit, bishop is hit, queen d6 is met with knight
takes knight check, and the queen would fall. Okay, simple defense after bishop e2, small
pawn center, no e5 to worry about. Okay, castles, rook c8. What is a thought or two? What's
an initial thought or two you have when you see rook to c8? If you'd like to, go ahead
and pause the video, maybe give this one 30 seconds. Okay, I'm just going to share some
of my own thoughts. My initial thoughts when I see rook c8 on a half open file, and the
queen, there's some kind of a pin going on. The queen probably doesn't feel so comfortable
opposite the rook. Here's something more you can think about once that king rook has made
a move. At the start of a chess game, the weakest square is f7. Given some development,
it goes from a weakened square to a strengthened square. Once castles is in there, the rook
is defending f7, but then a little bit later on, like right here, move 14, that king rook
has moved, f7 is back to a weak square. That's a natural progression in the game. It goes
from weak, strengthened, back to weak. There's clearly something that's going to happen in
this game on f7. Anyhow, I think it's helpful to recognize that little progression there.
Okay, coming up, rook f to e1. Last piece is activated, central here. Some regrouping
going on. These next two moves by black and white. The follow-up, knight e7. The suggestion
by the engine is to go forward kind of clog up the e-file. Be okay, in other words, taking
out these doubled pawns. Why doesn't Carlsen maybe play in this way? It does give white
a majority on the queen side. A much more static position ahead probably wanted to keep
it a bit more lively. Alright, he goes with knight to e7. Both bishop and rook are
unmasked. This is a window of opportunity for white. This is vulnerable now. White goes
after it with knight to b5 and opens up the bishop's eyes. So, how to defend d6? In the
game, the knight goes back to e8. What's considered best is to move this knight, allow the bishop
to defend. But if you play in this way, you're okay with taking on doubled f-pawns. Carlsen
was clearly not welcome to that. So, what does he play in this position? He drops the
knight back to e8. So these guys continue to compete with one another. You'll notice
when they're on these two squares competing for these two center points. And this move here,
black mimics it and goes to e8. And yet again, they continue to fight for these same squares.
Okay, who benefits with these last two moves? Knight b5, knight e8? It's clearly white. White's
moving forward, black's running in reverse. Okay white has promoted a piece, black has demoted
a piece. We continue now. In comes another knight move. Knight g5 creates...
There's some tactics now right around the corner. We can see pressure on
f7 and h7. We might now start to think about these two points as unprotected. One attacker,
one defender on each point. Actually, there's a third now that I look at it. Three unprotected
points, a lot of pressure with this one move. Also notice the queen, she's sandwiched between
the black rooks. She has no moves at all currently. Right around the corner for white is this
idea to push e5, and there'd already be a mate threat. Okay, this is one of the downsides
with retreating the knight. There's this sensitivity now on the h7 square. In the game, knight
g6 is played. However, what's important to note is that if the knight is given a kick
on this move 18, it would follow knight takes f7, and then e5, and two things are happening.
One, there's pressure on d6 three times, and if that's defended with, let's say, d5 trying
to close the position, white also would have this quiet but deadly queen h7, which cuts
off the king from returning to safe ground, and this would buy white time to swarm in
on the attack. One, for instance, bishop e2, bishop h5, completely crushing. We continue
in this game with knight g6, the follow-up, e5. So,
this is an excellent follow-up here. In fact, after knight g5, this was already
considered a winning move, move 18, knight g5. What's going on here? Well, here's the
simplest one to look at. Knight takes pawn would be game over. What other options are
there? In the game, d5 is played. If you take on e5, this is very painful. The queen's toast.
She doesn't have a square. You have to block with the knight. Okay, completely winning
for white. Same story here. Take the bishop, winning the king. So, in this game it is d5.
Queen b3, out of the pin. We continue bishop to e7. Instead of bishop e7, if h6, the follow-up
would be the same, and that is knight takes f7. Winning shot here. King takes knight.
Pawn takes pawn. And, what do you try in this position? The follow-up is bishop takes pawn. If you
try to attack the knight, the knight can hop into d6. Some capture on that square. White
would still have a pick. You could take in either direction. The position is opening
up for these two cannons. Right in the center, look at these guys. Not doing anything. This
position is officially broken down. What is played? Bishop takes on d5. That's not going
to hold up. Rook takes bishop. With this sequence, with this position, we now have two pawns
versus rook imbalance. But how good is this rook? Doesn't even have a move. Check on board.
Only one reply. King f8. The queen and knight. A killer combo. White is pouncing now on the
light squares. Big threat with knight e6. How do you deal with that? In the game, it's
knight f4. What other tries are there here? Let's say the bishop goes to h4 or e8, preparing
to meet a check with king to e7. First of all, this isn't a stable square. You can always
give the bishop a kick. Let's say the bishop is on this square. Here's how you continue
a check. Regardless of where the king goes, knight g5 is crushing. Let's stay off of this
diagonal. King here, knight here. How are you stopping this? Knight in the corner. This
is beginning to look like Fischer random chess. This would be mate in two. Check, checkmate.
Okay, what other variation is worth noting here? Again, the move in the game, knight f4. If
you try knight c7, this doesn't work. It hits the queen and defends knight e6, but white
would have queen f3 check. And what are black's options? If the king goes back home, white
can continue to build up the pressure. Bishop c4, looking at this. If you try to defend
with knight h8, there's knight f5. All the white pieces are swarming in. There is no
defense. And what would happen if the king went to the castled square, g8? Now would come
knight c6, hitting the queen. Any counterpunch against white's queen with rook f8 or knight
h4 can both be met with queen b3 check, and then the black queen would fall. What's the
problem after queen b7? Knight takes bishop check, and the queen would be won next. So, this
is not working. What's tried? Knight f4, queen f3, knight is pinned. No saving it. g5, there's
g3. Carlsen makes a run for it. Now we're not even... as white, white's not even down
material at this stage. It's a light square bishop and two pawns for the rook. But again,
how good is that rook? Alright, this one finishes up quickly. A 31 move game. Queen
b7, knight f5 paves the way for bishop c4 check. b5, the queen is now overloaded. Has
to watch over the pawn and bishop. White can simply take on b5, does take on b5. The bishop
is poison. Queen takes bishop would be met with knight takes bishop check. King in the
corner, queen f8, mate. So on this one it's bishop f8, bishop c4 check, king h8, final
move of this game. Knight h6, black resigns. What's happening here? We have a mate-in-one
threat. How do you deal with that? If you play queen e7, this is considered the best
try but it's still completely losing. White could continue with a check and even take
some time out to tuck the bishop away and you could wait to deliver a discovered check.
If let's say a5 in this position, there's knight g5, discovered check, and even a sacrifice
on h7 looking to next go for a rook lift. There is no defense to this play. Anything
else? Here's a fun one. If bishop to e7, white could play queen f7 and how does black stop
queen g8, mate? With a knight move, everybody would love to see this one. Queen g8 followed
up with knight f7 for a smothered mate. Simply no defense after knight h6. What did you think
of this one? Anyhow, feel free, as usual, to leave any feedback to this video in the
comments section below. I hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a thing or two away. That's
all for now. Take care. Bye.